I feel like when we were younger and
Rhythm started coming out older people
would be like this is robot music but
you're like no this is sick but this
doesn't even have drums it's just yeah
it's just that like it's crazy and I
think this younger generation is just
like Vape you know more media more just
pills
[Music]
so you're saying if you put music if you
if you were trying to get music in there
it's just like what's the most yeah so
now I feel like this is different
because it's taking that bit from
starships that makes you feel good yeah
and it's rammed up 500 bpms
so yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yes that's the part I know it's the only
thing that like compels them to not look
at Tick Tock yeah you know yeah